what do you think about the rounders
Teddy KGB when he does the Oreo tell do
players at the high level communicate
that kind of stuff do you think it's
realistic to be able to have a tell like
this that's partially subconscious so
first of all I love Brian koppelman who
made the film and uh I think what they
were going for is something obvious to
the general visually right like okay
it's very clear you know he eats the
cookie he doesn't eat the cookie and it
means one or the other at the highest
levels something that you know blatant
you're not gonna find you're gonna find
a lot more subtle things maybe with
posture or or timing or you know
different things like that but at the
lower levels you know you know you might
see some you might see you know with a
lot of people when they're in a hand and
they've bet whether they drink water in
the hand is going to tell you something
generally speaking it's such an intimate
part of the human experience that I feel
like if you have food you're going to
reveal something about yourself through
the way you eat I feel like that's a
dangerous thing to have with the table
well the thing is generally speaking
people don't eat food in the middle of a
hand like they're not gonna bet and then
just like I need Burgers right what they
will do though is you know they bet and
it's up to you and then they're whether
they're on you know uncomfortable or
they do it unconsciously they just want
to do something to make themselves look
relaxed or whatever you know they grab a
water where they don't really need it in
that moment but they're trying to take
your mind off of the situation
so they in the movie wanted to show a
simplistic version of something that
does happen something that's visually
sort of uh clear yeah because I think
one of the things rounders got right is
that it's a poker movie right but you
don't have to be great at poker really
understand poker to enjoy the movie and
that you know Oreo cookie tell like
everyone gets that they're like okay
that's simple if he would have went with
something more subtle you know like
licking your lips or looking to the
right and I think it might have been
lost on the audience and they didn't
actually explicitly
say that that was a tell I don't think
they thought they did everything to let
you know right with the music and slow
motion and he's staring at it and he's
like aha yeah but they didn't actually
say you know this is an obvious tell
like uh my famous characters at the very
end of it yeah you know after he he says
how the [ __ ] did you lay that down
monster right and he's like he's like
he's like you're not hungry not hungry
KGB he's like I keep on you know he sort
of references it and then he takes the
cookies he notices he's like ah he got
me and he breaks the you know the record
well probably if you had that kind of
tell on him you wouldn't and Matt
Damon's character would not reveal well
he says in the movie he says normally I
wouldn't reveal a tale but I don't have
that much time like I've got to Rattle
him some way yeah so that that was one
way to do that